so welcome to age 20 special relativity
it's a great pleasure to introduce david
kaiser david is a
faculty in the physics department
um he's also historian of science so
he's in a super great position to talk
about einstein and
special relativity and give kind of the
frame for this class so please welcome
david um and
you know take it along
great well hello everyone happy new year
uh welcome back at least virtually to
mit it's really a great pleasure um to
talk with you today about this material
i love this material
so hopefully you can all see that first
slide
smiling einstein on the bicycle okay
so i want to talk about three main um
parts today for for the for the material
i will talk about how
all the of of the kind of most
accomplished physicists were thinking
about
motion of bodies through space and time
during the middle and late years of the
19th century roughly say
100 to 150 years ago give or take
because that really sets up a pretty
sharp contrast with how at the time a
rather young and very a little known
person named albert einstein began
asking similar questions but often in
very different ways
so we'll start with some of this context
of what was happening before einstein
even came on the scene to help us better
make sense of why his approach seemed
really so unfamiliar and so surprising
at the time
and then for the last part it's i find
it really fascinating drawing on work
from some of my friends and colleagues
other historians will try to ask what
was going on with einstein why was
einstein's approach
so different than can we make sense of
it since it wasn't just the ordinary
routine that we might have otherwise
expected that's the last part about
coordinating clocks
let's jump right in let's start not with
albert einstein with another very
familiar name
uh james clark maxwell i thought about
growing a beard like that um during
covet i haven't made much progress but
that's a typical 19th century
fine cambridge beard cambridge england
so we all know maxwell's name many of
you probably own
a t-shirt with uh maxwell's equations on
it
if you do i'm very jealous i don't have
it anymore anyway so we we still use um
his approach to electromagnetism as of
course you all know very well and we've
been able to boil it down to basically a
tweet or a single t-shirt
it turns out as you may know what we now
call maxwell's equations
were were hammered out by maxwell and
actually some other colleagues during
the 1860s and early 1870s so
approximately 150 years ago
and in fact when he first wrote them
down they weren't in such a nice compact
form it was in a
900-page two-volume treatise that was
first published in 1873 two volumes a
total of 900 pages was a weapon it was
you could like hurt someone with these
books they were so fat
even though now we can boil it down to a
simple t-shirt
and so
what's even more interesting to me is
that even though we still use maxwell's
equations
what we think they say about the world
is really really different than what
maxwell and his immediate circle thought
and the biggest difference of all
is that for maxwell and really for all
of his contemporaries and his students
the equations of electricity and
magnetism as far as they were concerned
had everything to do with some
physical substance some medium that they
called the ether
that they assumed must have spread
evenly throughout the entire universe
filling every nook and cranny of space
so all of the phenomena that we would
associate with electricity uh or
mechanism the flow of currents um the
the splaying of iron filings
around a bar magnet and even much more
complicated things
to maxwell and his group these were all
just sort of evidence of the state of
stress
of this underlying kind of physical
medium was like a springy uh substantial
resistive medium that they called the
ether and he says that in the opening
pages for example of this now very
famous treatise and throughout that the
whole point of of studying this field as
far as he was concerned
was to study the behavior of the
distribution of stress in this medium
extending continuously throughout the
universe the ether
it wasn't just maxwell uh his uh a
little bit more senior colleague william
thompson who went on to be known as lord
kelvin like the kelvin temperature scale
and many things we we uh still use from
from uh thompson's work
uh
he wanted to give a sense to uh
non-scientists a few years later in a
popular lecture
what all the excitement was about he
said here's what we're doing we want to
get a sense of what what we're doing
we're studying the physics of this
elastic physical medium called the ether
and he instructed his very elite very
fancy audience who went to one of these
popular lectures
stick your hand in a bowl of jelly he
tells them and see how it wiggles and
vibrates as you move your hand around
that's the highest of high-end physics
in the 1860s and 70s it was all about
understanding that the behavior of this
elastic medium called the ether
and that had very specific um
follow-on implications for this group so
one of the first things that you all
know already one of the most exciting
features of maxwell's work that really
got himself excited and solidified his
reputation
was this unexpected unification that he
put together in the 1860s
not only was there a deep relationship
between electricity and magnetism that
had been wondered about but never really
formalized
but even more surprising
that these two areas electricity
magnetism were also deeply associated
with optics with the propagation of
light
so as maxwell as i'm sure you know and
probably have already done this on
problem sets by now yourselves
using maxwell's equations you can derive
the quantitative behavior of
light as it travels through space
light as maxwell um intuited
was nothing but a certain pattern of
propagating electric and magnetic and
magnetic fields again to maxwell these
were these were propagating in this
material physical ether they were
disturbances
propagating skittering through this
physical stuff that filled all of space
and in fact by trying to calculate the
speed with which disturbances would
travel through space
based on other properties of the ether
that he and his colleagues had already
measured basically sets of like spring
constants he found that the speed of
propagation would be equal to the value
that had already been calculated many
years before for the speed with which
light travels
and he says in his own words in this
lovely old-fashioned phrasing
the velocity of transverse undulations a
certain kind of wave
in our hypothetical medium agrees so
exactly with the velocity of light
calculated from optical experiments
mostly astronomy at the time
that we can scarcely avoid the inference
that light consists of the transverse
undulations of the same medium which is
the cause of electric and magnetic
phenomena that's why his book was 900
pages right today we put on a t-shirt he
was really just walking through this
very old-fashioned language to come to
the point saying light was nothing but
a certain kind of pattern in the ether
and so in fact they often called this
not just the ether
but an even fancier name they called it
the luminiferous ether and that stands
that's uh from the latin it means light
bearing or light carrying so lumen like
lumos for you harry potter fans that
part you probably recognize and the
ferris is like a like a ferris wheel
that means like to carry or to to to
kind of um
to move through space so this is the
light bearing or light carrying ether
and that's what maxwell and really all
of his contemporaries were convinced was
most exciting about maxwell's work uh
that this was a way of characterizing
the state of the ether including these
optical phenomena
okay so that's where things stood in the
1860s and 1870s
but that led to a whole new set of
questions and the next generation quite
understandably wanted to kind of follow
up on that and ask
kind of ways to generalize that
framework
maxwell's work had really assumed that
there was no relative motion between
either the source of light or the
receiver of light that everything was
analyzed in what we would now call the
same
kind of rest frame or frame of reference
as the ether itself but of course that
wasn't the most general situation as as
maxwell's own contemporaries was sort of
the next younger generation began to
wonder about
one of the most influential of that next
wave is this gentleman shown here
hendrick lorenz from the netherlands
from leiden
so laurence wanted to ask about the
electrodynamics of moving bodies what if
either the emitter of light or the
receiver or both were moving with
respect to this all-pervasive medium
and so lorenz as we'll see had really
two kind of distinct motivations in mind
when he when he tried to think about the
electrodynamics of moving bodies or
let's say optics for moving sources or
receivers
he had a kind of mathematical set of
quandaries we'll talk about those first
but he also had a series of very
puzzling experimental results so he had
a kind of empirical set of ideas we'll
come to in a moment and also these more
formal or mathematical ones we'll start
with the math
uh lorenz was really one of the the best
trained leading mathematical physicists
of his age so he knew very well how to
handle relative motion galileo had
derived that
in the 1610s that was hardly news in the
1890s
we would do what we still call the
galileo newton transformation that if
you have for example that galileo wrote
very famously in his charming dialogues
in the 17th century if you watch a
friend float down a river on a boat that
moves at a constant speed neither
speeding up or slowing down
then you know very well how to compare
the coordinates between you sitting at
rest on the on the back of that river
and your friend as she floats down on
her boat
that what you call the origin the
spatial origin of your coordinate system
you can fix at say x equals zero
but your friend could call the center of
her boat the origin for her coordinate
system and then you can see how your
system or how her system coordinates
will will um will move with respect to
yours if the boat moves at a constant
speed little v
then you just have to calculate the
offset between where the origin the
center of her boat is as it floats
further and further down the river so
what she calls
the origin of her spatial coordinates
will be offset from yours because it's
relative emotions relative drift
meanwhile as newton himself famously
said in the beginning of his um
principia
where we where we learn about uh
newton's laws of mechanics the time is
time is time there's some absolute time
he actually referred to the censorium of
god he thought there was only one
possible time to consider and so
formally there'd be no change to the
rate at which your clock ticked versus
the rate at which your friends clocked
ticked on her boat this is called the
galileo newton transformation i made a
big deal out of it you probably would
have done this in your sleep lorenz did
this in his sleep
however it drove him to nightmares
because when he then applied this to
maxwell's really beautiful and much
newer set of equations for things like
optics or the propagation of electric
and magnetic disturbances in the ether
he found that in that transformed
reference frame if you take into account
that relative motion between either
emitter or receiver of light
then maxwell's beautiful description of
light this quantitative description
looked very ugly and in particular it
would no longer suggest that light
should behave as kind of oscillating
sines and cosines it works beautifully
with maxwell's equations if you look
only at
both sources and receivers of light that
are that are fixed in place and not
moving with respect to the ether once
you apply the the very very well known
transformation to take into account
relative motion then your description of
light gets all literally out of whack
and this was a mathematical conundrum
for lorenz it didn't seem to make any
sense because on on the earth on the
moving earth presumably moving through
the ether
he and his colleagues could measure
light to behave like beautiful signs and
cosines all the time so we have an
empirical kind of um
reminder that maxwell's description
seems really really accurate for
describing optics even on our own moving
ship of the earth so this is a real
conundrum for him
he was a very very you know clever
mathematically gifted
physicist so he introduced a
mathematical clue she introduced a
mathematical um
stop gap to address this he called it
local time and he was actually very
clear in his writings he said it was a
mathematical fiction his word it was
literally just a mathematical trick
if he introduced a new transformation
for the time variable so when you
compare your coordinates with those of
your friend on the boat what if you
actually did make a transformation of t
t prime not just of x prime
and the transformation he kind of worked
out he kind of reverse engineered the
form it would need to have
so that maxwell's description of light
waves would be restored to the very
simple form uh that maxwell himself had
written down a few years earlier
so this is where we still call this the
wrench transformation many of you might
have seen it if not you'll have plenty
of time to learn about it and practice
it during iap
we call it lorentz not einstein because
lorenz derived these equations first in
a series of papers in the 1890s
and he was responding to this question
of the electrodynamics of moving bodies
how do you preserve this beautiful
description of light from maxwell even
if there's relative motion with respect
to the ether he said it was a trick it
was merely mathematics but it would at
least get the right form back
so that was the kind of mathematical
motivation lorenz as we know was also
concerned about an empirical or
experimental curiosity
he was following very closely
the work of the u.s based physicist
named albert michaelson michaelson's
story is really fascinating i won't take
too much time now but um super
interesting
he was actually an immigrant from
what's now germany was often part of
poland kind of central europe he moved
to the us when he was about two years
old there young and was raised right
around the time of the gold rush in
california and before he get carried
away i'll stop talking about michaels
and although he's super interesting so
what michaelson wound up doing
was he was fascinated by this question
of maxwell waves of waves of electricity
and magnetism in the ether
and he was convinced that if we are on
this moving ship of the earth moving
through the ether that should have a
measurable impact on the light waves
that we can produce and measure here on
earth
so he set really his life's goals
starting from very very early
trying to build devices extremely
sensitive instruments with which he
could measure the fact that the earth
was moving through this ether like all
his contemporaries michaelson believed
without any hesitation that there must
exist this the material the ether uh
what else could light waves be but
disturbances in the ether
and then he figured that much like if a
bicyclist on a on a
going for a bike ride we should be able
to tell that we're moving through that
medium so before i describe his device
called the interferometer let me just
give a little more kind of analogy for
why michaelson was so convinced there
should be a measurable effect
if we walk outside our houses which is
now a luxury we can still do it with
masks on
walk outside on a still day when there's
no wind or no breeze we won't feel any
particular wind on our face if we're
standing still
so we're outside in a physical medium
there's a physical atmosphere but if
we're at rest with respect to that
atmosphere if there's no wind we don't
feel it on our face
on the other hand if it's still
a still day there's no breeze when we
get on our bicycle and pedal really
quickly we'll now feel a breeze on our
face because we're moving through that
physical medium we're moving through the
earth's atmosphere
even if the atmosphere seems to be
perfectly at rest no strong breeze no
hurricane whatever
if we're going quickly enough through it
we'll feel a breeze on our face
and michaelson thought the same thing
should be happening for light waves as
they are carried by the earth through
this medium
not the earth's atmosphere but this
all-pervasive light bearing ether so we
really thought it'd be like the
bicyclist
now his his real genius was devising
this device we now call it the
interferometer with which he could try
to measure the impact of that motion of
the earth the entire earth through the
medium
so we took a source of light today we
use lasers because they're awesome and
they're also monochromatic their light
shines at basically one
frequency or very dominantly one
frequency lasers of course weren't
available to michelson so he used um
very bright sodium arc lamps sodium
lamps will shine mostly at one dominant
color not nearly so monochromatic as
modern lasers but they were the kind of
industry standard of the time so we
basically took sodium lamps that mostly
shine as a particularly yellow color
shine them at what we would now call a
beam splitter it was a half silvered
mirror as its name implies that would
let half the light through it would act
like a window roughly half the time
but act like a mirror the other half the
time so half of this incident beam will
go right through this as if it were just
a plate of glass it would be transmitted
it will then make its way to a fully
reflecting mirror sorry a fully
reflecting mirror at the end of the path
it'll be reflected to come back and then
again half of that return light will be
reflected by the mirror and come out to
a screen
meanwhile you can run the same kind of
story for light that gets deflected
towards path two from that same single
incident source
half of the incident being will be
reflected by that beam splitter half
silver mirror it'll travel a path down
to a fully reflecting mirror come back
and then half of that returning light
will be transmitted so you have light
coming together on some detector screen
that started out as a single light wave
from a single nearly monochromatic
source
but you split it into two beams so the
beams travel different paths and now the
light starts out fully in phase with
itself it's one light beam so crests are
with crests and troughs with troughs
and the idea was that you then split it
to set up a race
to see
if there's any difference in the travel
for light that traveled through path one
and out to the screen
versus like the traveled path to and
back to the screen now all the light
starts uh as a single light wave in sync
or in phase of itself it was if there
was any difference in the travels of
that light between path one and part two
you should see a shift in the
interference patterns crests should no
longer arrive lining up with crests or
troughs with troughs you should see a
very characteristic set of interference
fringes what's called an interferometer
extremely sensitive
now his idea was if if like the
bicyclist
we're on the moving earth then the path
that's heading directly into the ether
the that is a the path that's along the
earth's motion through the ether
should be just like the bicyclist
feeling the direct kind of headwind of
that of that breeze directly on on her
or his face
that means the effective speed let's say
this is the direction of the earth's
motion the effective speed with which
this light beam could travel toward its
mirror
should be experienced a direct headwind
for its upward uh path and a direct
tailwind for its downward path it should
have a different speed than this or the
light that follows some orthogonal path
so that even the light starts out
perfectly in phase you should find a
shift in the interference fringes
because the light's effective speed
through the medium
uh is different for path one than path
two
again an analogy to the ether wind of a
bicyclist through the atmosphere
not only that is a little uh
foreshadowing for what's to come later
this device is so sensitive it's
sensitive to second order in a very
small quantity
so if there was any um
it could measure differences to the
second order in the relative speed of
say the earth through the ether
compared to the the speed of light
so that's called a second order because
it goes like this small quantity squared
that's how sensitive is really ingenious
device was and as many of you might know
we use interferometers all the time now
in all kinds of industrial applications
even more my favorite example is from
our friends
who
detect gravitational waves with ligo
that's essentially a super-sized
interferometer with very very similar
principles of design so michelson was
doing this really cool work it was among
the earliest work that any of the super
fancy elite european scientists paid any
attention to
coming out of the u.s michaelson was
among the first who made even the people
like hendrick lorenz sit up and pay
attention
at a time when the u.s was still
otherwise
pretty much a scientific backwater
so it's a really cool idea it's a
remarkably
clever design for device
michaelson built a small prototype then
he supersized it with his colleague
edward morley they built a device 11
meters long for each arm so you know
roughly 33 or 34 feet long huge huge for
this day
very long arms they floated the whole
thing in a vat of mercury which i don't
recommend but they're trying to tamp
down any vibrations from nearby cable
cars
they want to have a clean laboratory
environment then they did this for years
and years and years months and months
and years and years because of course
you never know what the
what the ether's actual rest frame is
who's to say that at this moment this is
the direction of the earth's motion to
the ether maybe it's this direction or
some other angle in between
they would look for day-to-night
variations they would look for annual
variations as the earth went around its
orbit around the sun they would try to
find any time
day or night
winter versus spring year after year
when they could measure some measurable
offset uh or change in the in those
interference fringes because at some
point this direction should have lined
up with the earth's direction of motion
even it wouldn't be every time that's
why they kept doing this over and over
and over again
and as you might know
they found
nothing
so after years of painstaking
data collection
they found no
no
compelling empirical evidence of the
earth's motion through the ether
michelson won the nobel prize for this
and related work he was a
astoundingly accomplished
experimentalist he was the first u.s
based physicist to win the nobel prize
he lived 20 more years after that and
died considering himself a failure
so
i hope you all win the nobel prize and i
hope you think better of yourselves and
give yourselves more credit
uh michelson knew for certain the ether
must exist and yet he had failed to find
it so lorenz was following this back in
europe and this was really his second
main motivation to think about
these funny ways of handling coordinates
and what we now call the lorenz
transformation so i mentioned his
mathematical concerns about the
transformation properties of of
maxwell's equations he was also
following um uh the michaels and morley
work with great interest in citing it
and we know he was really following each
update
so he was concerned about this failure
to measure
a shift in the interference fringes
but lorenz said oh but actually maybe
there's a physical reason to account for
that
if there really is as he
knew there must be this physical
resistive medium a kind of elastic
medium through which uh the earth and
everything else is moving then there
must be a force
exerted by that kind of viscous medium
on every single atom and molecule making
up all the stuff in michaelson's device
as well as in everything else
and so it'd be like picturing a beach
ball
well if you try to drag a beach ball
under water in a resistive medium the
shape will be deformed along the
direction of motion if you drag that
beach ball fast enough underwater
it will shrink in the direction of
motion be deformed
like this picture here
and so lorenz said that must be
happening for every bit of matter
in the arm of michelson's interferometer
that's that's most subject to that
resistive force of the ether there
should be a contraction along the
direction of motion so then again
because he's a very gifted mathematical
physicist he calculated exactly how much
shift must there be
for the resultant path
to be shortened just enough to make it a
tie race after all so the leg of the or
the arm and the infrared that's
experiencing this shrinking this extra
force due to the resistive medium
would have to shrink by a specific
calculable amount we now call it use the
greek letter gamma if you don't haven't
seen that already you'll see it
throughout iap and the rest of your life
it takes this
somewhat simple looking form 1 over the
square root of 1 over 1 minus v over c
squared
if you plot it you can see it diverges
at when when the relative speed gets
close to the speed of light you have 1
minus 1 in the denominator you divide by
zero your eyes bug out cats and dogs
live together everything goes crazy so
it diverges at v equals c
on the head for small speed small
compared the speed of light this factor
is indistinguishable from one so here's
a quick plot
for ordinary speeds that we encounter on
the highway let alone on a bicycle
our speed compared to the speed of light
is is vanishingly small so this factor
gamma is that is very very close to one
only when you get to speeds approaching
the speed of light would you expect to
to measure any shift from that
nonetheless lorenz said in principle
this happens at any speed
and they shrink the amount of
contraction is governed by that relative
speed given by this this greek letter
gamma so gamma is always greater than or
equal to one that means one over gamma
must be um smaller than one and that's
saying that the contracted length of one
of those arms of the interferometer got
shorter
by a certain amount given by or
depending on
the relative speed that would be enough
to account for this null result lorentz
argued it turned out that exact form of
gamma was the same form he'd found for
his mathematical kind of um local time
manipulations so here's how we can live
in a physical ether even though we don't
measure its effects okay
let me now shift to how uh a different
person began thinking about very
familiar questions by that point but
coming at them quite differently that's
young albert einstein
so einstein was born in the midst of all
this he was born in 1879
in kind of rural roughly speaking
nowheresville germany not near any of
the big cities so laurence was already
a practicing physicist when einstein was
born he was much younger
einstein's main ambition was actually to
become an electrical engineer at a time
when that term itself was actually brand
new
uh einstein's father and uncle had gone
into business together in this really
brand new field of electrical
engineering this is the age of
electrification think about extended
street lighting uh trolley cars with
with the shared electric
lines above this was transforming the
face of everyday life in cities and
eventually even in more rural areas and
einstein's father and uncle were were in
on that they were early professionals in
this new field of electric engineering
and einstein loved it he loved to tinker
with electro technical
gadgets
his he had many strong feelings about
many things among them he hated what he
considered the overly militaristic
german high school that he attended
he would argue and insult
his teachers they didn't like him any
better they were delighted when he
dropped out so they didn't have to kick
him out he was really very obnoxious it
turns out so he dropped he was a high
school dropout
he dreamed of entering uh the swiss
federal uh
federal um technical institute it was
kind of like the mit of switzerland
except to be more proper mit is the
is the uh massachusetts version of their
school zurich was was founded first it's
often called the eth or the ignorance
technician
it was really a very elite technical
university in zurich switzerland
einstein by this point had renounced his
german citizenship he dropped out of
high school and one of the best things
about this technical university in
zurich was that you didn't have to have
a high school diploma he said perfect
that's the place for me
so they had an entrance exam which he
very dutifully studied for and then
failed because after all he ignored the
topics that weren't of interest for him
he he did well enough on the physics and
math portions of the overall exam
that a kind of kindly physics professor
took him aside and said you know if you
go to basically a kind of regional
something like almost a community
college go to a local regional school
for a year
study up retake the exam you might do
better and that's what einstein did so
he went to a little regional school in
um again in rural switzerland for a year
took the exam again and passed so now
he's able to enter his dream school the
eth in zurich
once he then worked so hard to get in he
proceeded to cut classes this guy was a
horrible student whatever you do don't
be like albert einstein at least while
you're in university
he works so hard to get in and then he
again would insult his professor as much
as he'd insulted his high school
teachers he thought everything that they
did was boring they didn't know what was
really interesting so he would cut
classes and read on his own and then
borrow notes from his girlfriend his
long-suffering very patient girlfriend
maleva marich who was doing very well in
her own physics and math courses and
likewise he borrowed notes from another
friend of his martha grossman so he just
cram and scrape through for the exams
not an ideal student
for some reason einstein couldn't
possibly fathom because he actually was
adult frankly
he
impressed none of his professors so when
it came time to graduate none of them
would write him a strong letter of
recommendation again his life bears many
important lessons for us today
uh go attend class and be um
slightly less obnoxious to your
instructors and maybe things will turn
out better so none of his teachers would
basically support him because he had
middling grades and he was rude to them
so he couldn't get a job after
graduation
so finally uh of one of his close
friends marcel grossman one of the folks
from whom he'd borrow notes
his father had connections and so the
basically through connections he was
able to get einstein an entry-level
civil service job at the patent office
in barron switzerland so still in
switzerland he was a patent officer
third class as i'm always fond of saying
there was no fourth class that was
literally the lowest entry-level gig
so even for you einstein it wasn't what
you know
it was who you know
what he then proceeded to do
was he had a day job at what they called
the electro technical desk much like
what his father and uncle were doing he
was a patent examiner for a lot of these
cool new electrical gadgets
and then he would go hang out with a
bunch of friends and drink beer a lot at
the at the pubs
so they formed what they called the
olympia academy and this was very ironic
they gave themselves the most elite
sounding name because they're basically
three semi-bums hanging out reading and
blowing off their families so they gave
this was a very very prestigious name
even though it was literally three
recent college graduates hanging out
it was um maurice sullivan conrad had
peach and young albert einstein and they
would go and sometimes drink coffee
often drink beer and talk about stuff
they'd read and they would read a lot of
physics and read a lot of philosophy and
talk about it
and one of the books that we know from
their
correspondence at the time that they
were really interested in was this
fascinating book by an austrian polymath
named aarons mock here's the book
translated into english known as the
science of mechanics it had come out
in the 1880s
mock was really remarkable he was
both a mathematical physicist and
experimental physicist you might know
the terminology for mach number like
speed of sound mach 1 mach 2 mach 3
seymour he did a lot of studies of
acoustics and optics but also of what we
would now call psychology like sensory
experiments and so on
and eventually a medical surgery and
then at the end of his career he was a
professor of the history and philosophy
of science this guy did it all
he wrote these very very dense um
conceptual critiques of newtonian
physics among other things and he was
mark was convinced that newton was
really getting getting himself into a
horrible muddle
because he had not paid sufficient
attention philosophically and this is
what the young members of the olympia
academy got really excited about we know
from their letters and their notes at
the time mark was was
advocating a position that came to be
known as positivism
according to ants mock unlike isaac
newton
or for that matter even some folks like
maxwell
mach argued that only quantities that
could become objects of positive
experience let's say things we could
actively measure
or sense or feel or touch
only those things belonged
in our scientific theories anything else
was just like mere speculation
like you know counting the number of
angels that could dance on the head of
the pin he was scathingly critical of
newton
and in particular mock wrote in detail
that newton's notions of absolute space
and absolute time had no meaning because
how could you ever measure absolute time
show me the clock that could measure
absolute time that was the kind of
classic machine response i can measure
the passage of time by using a clock but
who says that's what newton wrote
absolute time was this had an amazing
impact as we as we know
on the young einstein
so it's in this milieu he's now not in
the university setting he'd scrape
through his undergraduate studies
he has a nice day job but he's not doing
particularly well professionally he's
hanging out with his buddies in reading
some interesting and hard
obscure kind of philosophy science uh in
the evenings
where he has what's now commonly called
his miraculous year his honest mirabilis
in 1905. in fact he only took about six
months it was like half a year
during which he submitted four really
astonishing original papers to the
leading journal of physics the honolulu
physique in germany at the time
they've since been published and
translated there's a particularly nice
addition you can find edited by uh john
stachel uh with very nice um essays to
accompany them you can find them online
so for for iap and for the rest of today
and even throughout the month
we're really interested in what was the
third of these articles that he
submitted he submitted to the journal in
june of 1905 it's on what we would now
call special relativity its title as you
can see up top was actually in
translation
on the electrodynamics of moving bodies
a thoroughly familiar title exactly what
lorenz and all of laurence's colleagues
have been talking about for for decades
by that point so the title of einstein's
paper in 1905 was not surprising even
though as we'll see his approach was
quite distinct
he begins this now
very well known paper
not by saying i found an error in
lorenz's calculation there's a missing
factor of two pi or you know whatever he
doesn't say i conducted my own
measurements and i found these results
within experimental error
he starts out by saying there's an
asymmetry in the explanation
which is not present in the phenomena it
sounds very philosophical
he goes on in this very opening
paragraph
to say
that when we use maxwell's equations
we come up with very different kinds of
accounts for what should be the same
phenomenon very simple nothing super
fancy like an interferometer just take a
bar magnet and a coil through which
current could flow
and make sure you have a current meter
an ammeter attached to the coil so if
current flows electric current flows
through the coil it will be measured the
ammeter needle will be deflected and we
are free to move either the magnet or
the coil
in this opening paragraph einstein says
physicists had treated this situation
completely orthogonally even though
einstein was concerned as far as that's
concerned there's only one explanation
needed
and so with case one if you assume the
bar magnet is moving you're shaking the
magnet back and forth and keeping the
coil fixed in location
then you would appeal to one set of
maxwell's equations and again on on the
t-shirt you'll be this one you have a
time-varying magnetic field
which will induce a spatially varying
electric field and that will exert a a
push a force on the little ions little
electric charges within that coil
they'll feel a push they'll move along
the coil electric current as maxwell
himself had argued was nothing but the
motion of these electric um electric
charge bearers
so because of a time varying magnetic
field the the little bits of matter in
the coil will be pushed along you'll
induce a current that's case one moving
magnet stationary coil
but if you want to analyze the other
situation hold the magnet rigidly fixed
in place
and shift the coil back and forth then
physicists would give an entirely
separate explanation they would appeal
to a different one
of maxwell's equations now they'd say
that there's a static magnetic field
varied in space its spatial gradients
were non-vanishing
and that would exert a a force like a
kind of lorentz force law on those
charges so they're moving they have some
velocity in a magnetic field they'll be
pushed along the wire then you'll
measure a current einstein said that's
one explanation too many all that we
could ever measure again you can almost
hear the kind of mock coming through
all we can ever see as an element of
positive experience is some relative
motion between the magnet and the coil
which induces an electric current who's
to say one was actually still while the
other was moving so einstein begins this
paper by saying that there's something
wrong with with the stories we tell
about the equations he doesn't argue
about the equations he argues about our
interpretation of equations very
striking
he then goes on just in like paragraph
three still very early in the
introduction
to posit two postulates he doesn't prove
them he doesn't derive them he doesn't
say i have uh demonstrated these by
doing experiments he just pop he says
let me hypothesize these and see what
follows
and these are the two in in rough
paraphrase
the first one
was actually already called the
principle of relativity or sometimes
simply called a galilean relativity
going back again to the 17th century
galileo had argued by thinking about
that
that boat floating down the river that
to a person on the boat as long as the
boat is moving at a constant speed
neither speeding up or slowing down that
all the laws of mechanics should work
perfectly well for that observer as if
the same as they would for us at rest on
on the shore
if you toss a boat it'll land back in
your hand as you expect even though to
us we see the ball uh trace a
complicated parabola to the person on
the boat she's a perfect entitled to say
i'm sitting at rest the ball went
straight up and let it straight back in
my hand all the laws of mechanics should
work equally well in any reference frame
that's moving at a constant speed
einstein just takes that existing
principle of relativity from mechanics
and just assumes just hypothesizes that
that should apply not only to mechanics
but to every physical phenomenon
electricity magnetism optics
thermodynamics and that's just a leap he
just says what if what if this applies
to any kind of physical phenomenon not
just mechanics
and then he introduces the second
postulate
which seems actually to be in tension a
bit with the first
his second passage is the speed of light
is a constant independent of the motion
of the source
what that doesn't sound right if you go
back to galileo and watching his friend
on the boat if she you know fires a
cannon the speed with which we measure
the cannonball is different than speed
she measures it
right
for if if you're if you're if you watch
her lobbing a tennis ball
our measurement of the speed of an
object on her reference frame is not the
same as ours and einstein here is saying
light is special
that unlike tennis balls ping pong balls
cannonballs or trains or anything else
the speed of light as a postulate will
be constant for any mode any observer as
long as they're in an inertial frame of
reference
and here's an excerpt from the english
translation
i won't read all this out but he says
what follows from these postulates is
that the luminiferous ether will prove
to be superfluous uber
he doesn't say i've just proven the
ether he says it's just irrelevant
50 years worth by that point 100 years
worth of study by all of europe's most
prestigious physicists was irrelevant
that's probably why he didn't have many
friends in physics at the time so he
doesn't disprove the either he says we
just won't even need to refer to anymore
it makes the entire set of questions
that are driven people like lorenz
really kind of fall away at least at
least as far as einstein himself is
concerned
so why does einstein introduce that
second possum again historians and
physicists uh philosophers have studied
this question a lot
and we have some good documentary
evidence because einstein was writing
letters and diaries and stuff all the
time and a lot of those have survived so
we have some contemporaneous
documentation as well as his own later
recollections and so on
we know that actually 10 years before
this paper back when islam was was a
mere teenager
he'd like to pose these kind of thought
experiments or questions to himself and
one of the questions he would return to
really over the course of a full decade
was what would it look like what would
you experience if you could catch up to
a light wave any reason it would be like
a surfer
riding along an ocean wave
that to us on the shore we'd see both
these things moving we would see a
dynamical wave moving over time not just
not just a frozen waveform in space but
to the surfer if she's really moving at
the same speed as the wave
then she would see the wave frozen in
space it should be frozen in time it
would be a crest here a trough there but
the surfer wouldn't see at least for
some extent a period of time the surfer
would see the wave frozen not
dynamically a frozen wave form
a varying in space but frozen in time
so einstein said that doesn't make any
sense if we think about maxwell's
equations when he got a little more
sophisticated and learn more about
maxwell he said there's no solution to
maxwell's equations
if you're in a source-free region if
there's no clump of electric charge
around no electric currents around if
both rho and j vanish
then there's no way to have spatially
varying electric and magnetic fields
that are nonetheless static right
that seems to be a contradiction so how
do you get out of this contradiction of
thinking you would have a static
waveform of light if you could catch up
and move at the same speed as that light
wave
how do you avoid that you just make sure
you can never catch up to the wave
how can you never ever catch up to the
wave if the wave is always traveling at
the speed c even if you're traveling on
a very fast train or now you know a
hypersonic jet or a spaceship of your
imagination
that second postulate for einstein we
now know
was was really the end point of a
10-year series of thought experiments
about what would it look like to catch
up with a light wave he said that would
be that would make so many other things
mutually inconsistent let's make sure no
one can ever catch a light wave and
that's what starts driving much of the
rest of his thinking not worrying about
you know interferometers and all the
rest so what he does unlike lorentz and
really all the all the masters in the
field at the time
uh einstein begins with kinematics with
the most with the force-free motion of
bodies through space and time which is a
very mocking thing to do what can we see
we measure objects moving through space
and time
whereas people like lorenz and maxwell
for that matter have been starting with
forces with dynamics remember lorenz has
this great idea that there's a force
from the ether on the matter in the in
michaelson's instrument it's all about
dynamics forces
einstein inverts that order because
force is really important but first
let's make sure we understand force-free
motion kinematics first after all that's
that's what could become objects of
positive experience
and so he has these wonderful quotations
is now from from the introduction of the
paper it's on the bottom of page two
he's really redescribing how to lay out
coordinates it sounds ultimately it
sounds childish it sounds thoroughly uh
unprofessional to the to the folks of
the time
hendrick lorette says don't you
don't bother with with what do we mean
by coordinates but einstein was
convinced we have to think through how
do we describe motion to space and time
first and i won't bother reading it out
i'll share this slide you can see it but
that's really what he's doing in the
very opening paragraphs of this paper
and that leads him to other follow-up
conclusions one of which very famously
becomes known as the relativity of
simultaneity you might have heard of
that before but you'll spend more time
at this iap i'm sure
if there's no such thing as absolute
time if time is what we measure with
time measuring devices like clocks if
that's all time is is what can be
measured by an actual instrument like a
clock
then how can we measure how can we
compare the times in different places
after i'm sitting here with my clock
which is one thing we could do
is trade light signals because by at
least according to his postulate number
two light is special
if i throw ping pong balls that's not so
special because we will disagree on the
speed
with which those ping-pong balls travel
if i send a light wave then we could
better agree
on the speed with which that light moved
from point a to point b because of
postulate 2.
so we start thinking about one of his
favorite things in the universe trains
he loved trains they come up all the
time
so he imagines a train moving along a
platform at a constant speed a nice
inertial frame of reference
einstein is standing here on the
embankment the train platform
he has two friends we can call them
alice and bob
a and b
uh he ellenstein has marked himself out
to be in the perfect midpoint of where
alice and bob are standing
so they mark this all out ahead of time
he marks himself perfectly in the middle
alice and bob are each equipped with a
lantern and a watch
and by prior arrangement they say at 12
noon on the dot turn on your lanterns so
the light will will travel from both a
and b toward the midpoint
point your lanterns toward einstein at
point m
turn them on at the same time
meanwhile on this zooming back
train
there's another uh friend of einstein
sitting at the midpoint of the train at
the point there's march m prime here
she knows that she's the exact midpoint
of the train
she knows by prior arrangement that
alice and bob are standing one train
length apart from each other
and again she's expecting that they will
turn their lanterns on at the same time
so how do these different folks describe
the series of events that follow
let's focus first on what einstein sees
when he's standing still on the train
platform the embankment watching the
train go by
the observer who's standing still on the
platform at point m
was by prior arrangement an equal
distance from uh alice and bob
i guess i changed it now it's a she so
um maleva his wife uh he's staying there
maybe m stands for millennial so she
receives a light weight from points a
and b at the same time so she can
conclude that the light flashes were
emitted at the same time the the event
of person a and person b shining their
lights those events were simultaneous
how do you know
because the light had equal distances to
travel
and the light could only travel by at
but one speed and they were arrived at
the same time they must have started the
journeys at the same time the act of
shining those lanterns must have been
simultaneous
but what about the person who's move
who's on the moving train
she
sees the following uh as she's zooming
along at point m prime
she sees the light from point b arrive
at her location first now we malevo or i
say would say oh that's because you're
racing toward it she says not so fast
i'm in a perfectly self-consistent
mechanical system
all the laws of physics work as well for
me is for you
and the light couldn't have sped up or
slowed down by your own postulate she
would say she would be entitled to say
so if she's equal distance between
points a and b and she receives the
light from b first the only possible
explanation
is that the lights were not shown
simultaneously that a and b did not turn
their lanterns on at the same time
so the person of the on the train
platform and the person on the moving
train disagree about what happens
simultaneously this becomes known as the
relativity of simultaneity so who's
correct i've already said according to
einstein no one or both of them
because of posture one
they're both entitled to work out a
perfectly self-consistent set of uh of
of laws involving electromagnetism
optics and mechanics
they agree they are at the midpoint they
agree that light didn't speed up or slow
down so they are both right which is to
say there is no right answer to the
question what was really simultaneous
simultaneity becomes relative to one's
frame of reference that's a pretty deep
change from the newtonian system and as
as einstein says against bottom of page
two very early in the paper
we see that we can attribute no absolute
meaning to the concept of simultaneity
but the two events which examined from a
coordinate system are simultaneous like
him on the embankment
can no longer be interpreted as
simultaneous events when examined from a
system which is in motion relative to
that system okay that's about kinematics
he's not about forces or resisted medium
or uh or dynamics
so now he goes on again very early on in
the paper
once you get to the relativity of
simultaneity again as you'll have a
chance to unpack
with more patience in the coming days
and weeks
other strange phenomena seem to follow
from that argues einstein one of the
first he talks about is length
contraction
so this had been found and published by
lorenz einstein's about to give an
entirely different derivation even
though quantitatively it's the same form
of the equation
for einstein has nothing to do with
forces it's all about um kinematics how
to in general like a good machine he
asks how do we measure the length of an
object how do we make length an object a
positive experience
well at the same time measure the
location the front of the object and the
back of the object and take the
difference so if you want to measure the
length of the train that's fine just
measure where the front is and the back
is at the same time
and then mark off the difference between
those two locations in space
our friends alice and bob can do that
with the train
and they uh find the answer capital l
the train is
length l long
meanwhile
uh alice and bob uh that's i should i'm
sure that's when the train is at rest
when they do this with a moving train
alice and bob measure the length of the
moving train
they measure some some length shorter
than what the person on the train was
expecting
the person on the train expected the
full length l
the person who's moving with the object
either at rest with it or moving
together with it
says the train is l units long but when
alice and bob measure the train by
measuring the front and back at the same
time they find a shorter answer they
found it shrunk along the direction of
motion by some specific amount
now how could that be remember we
disagree about at the same time so if we
disagree about simultaneity we will per
force we must start to disagree about
lengths so the person on the train says
you did your measurement wrong
you measured point the front of the
train first we know that
event b happened first she says because
we got the light from from event b first
so you measured the front of the train
and then waited while the train slid and
then later measured the position of the
rear of the train so of course you have
a shorter distance because you performed
a bad measurement because you didn't
measure the front and back at the same
time
we say don't be silly they were at the
same time we checked by uh trading light
beams we know they were simultaneous and
we got the answer l prime your train is
short who's right sort of both and
neither
that because we disagree on simultaneity
we just agree on on the outcomes of
simultaneous events like measurements of
length
and so he goes on with just a few lines
of algebra to find the exact form of
what was already known as the lorenz
contraction the same factor gamma that
you'll be using all
iap
that the the measurement of an object in
motion shrinks along the direction of
motion whereas if we were at rest with
an object we find a longer length and
the amount it shrinks depends on that
relative speed v over c
depends in particular on this form gamma
this has nothing for einstein to do with
forces or dynamics it's a totally
different derivation to lorenz's it's
simply a consequence of kinematics and
in particular about simultaneity
uh it's a very simple exercise you'll
probably end up doing it very soon
to find a similar consequence for the
rate at which clocks will tick this is
now became known as time dilation
imagine a very simple kind of clock the
simplest one
two highly polished mirrors with a light
beam that just bounces straight back and
forth between them
if the clock is at rest with respect to
us we hold the clock perfectly still at
a fixed height
then the time it takes for that light to
travel
from the bottom mirror to the top mirror
will count as one tick of our clock
and we know that light can only travel
at a fixed speed so it's a really great
uniform clock as long as we can hold
that height really fixed this is a great
way of defining a unit of time and
therefore our clock rate
what happens if our friend has an
identical clock same mirrors held
equally rigidly at the same height apart
but zooming past us on that moving train
then we watch the light have to travel
this longer path
because but after the light beam leaves
the bottom mirror in order to reach the
top mirror the whole assembly has moved
with the train to the right some
distance v times t
in the in the time during which that
light beam was was in transit
so it has to travel the hypotenuse of
this right triangle instead of just a
simple up and down it travels per force
a longer distance and likewise back down
so our observation
of the moving clock is that it takes
longer
between ticks
that becomes known as time dilation the
time between ticks has stretched which
is to say the time the clock is running
slowly as we measure
we measure the moving clock to run
slowly by that same factor gamma
the time between ticks gets stretched
remember gamma is is greater than
one
so the time between ticks gets stretched
and that's the thing that the clock is
running slowly meanwhile the person on
the train says you're ridiculous i had
the clock with me the whole time it kept
perfect time but your clock ran slowly i
watched as i ran by the station
perfectly symmetrical conclusions
so einstein was working those all this
out very much inspired by uh airsmach by
this notion of positivism of what can we
hope to measure uh not starting with
forces but with with the force-free
motion of objects through space and time
and really trying to bring it back to
what would be measurable what would i
see if i were in this situation
one of his teachers at the eth
a mathematician named heman minkowski
had formed a deservedly low opinion of
student einstein i used to cut class i
was very rude
one of their mutual friends after
einstein's paper came out
sent the paper to minkowski saying you
know it's actually kind of interesting
to take a look to paraphrase and
mankowski said well
despite the fact that i knew einstein
was up was was never going to amount to
anything i read the paper and i was
right mccaskey says he really made a
mess of this as well
so mankowski is just interested enough
to redo einstein's work in a form that
made much more sense to minkowski who
was after all a professional geometer
he wasn't just a mathematician he loved
geometry most of all
so mankowski not einstein is the one who
actually brings these pieces together a
few years later in it was published in
1908 instead of 1905
and he says all this talk about moving
trains and and polished mirrors all
that's just a distraction
to a properly trained mathematician
which einstein was not
all we're doing is performing rotations
or projections in a certain kind of
space
in this case a space time
in which there's say one direction of
space running along the horizontal axis
and one dimension of time running up the
page we now call these minkowski
diagrams in his honor or simply
space-time diagrams
none of this appears in einstein's early
work this was done by his former teacher
in response to
what mckowski's considered to be
einstein's continuing confusion and
sloppiness
and there's a benefit from doing that
minkowski finds
he agrees with einstein that we will
that we will disagree on certain kinds
of measurements for example lengths and
durations of time
because we disagree on simultaneity but
minkowski finds something that had not
been so clear to einstein himself there
are combinations of those kinds of
intervals on which we will all agree
there's what we would now call a
space-time invariant
put together a combination of the time
interval
minus the space interval
a relative minus sign that that comma
and each of those quantity squared that
combination we will all agree on as long
as we're each in states of um of
non-accelerating motion
even though we disagree separately on
the duration between two events delta t
or the lengths between them delta x and
that for minkowski is what any geometer
should do
some relationships remain invariant even
under changes of coordinates and for
mikowski that was what any
undergraduate geometry student should
know to do first so we actually have
this notion of one kind of thing called
space time
coming from minkowski kind of redoing
isis work and as mikowski famously
writes in his own article was published
posthumously he died quite young and he
gave a lecture and it was published soon
after he died
and he wrote upon introducing this new
work
henceforth space by itself and time by
itself are doomed to fade away into mere
shadows
and only a kind of union of the two
will preserve independence by shadows he
really meant projections just drop a
perpendicular to the appropriate axis
and then think about uh coordinate
transformations in that
space time of x and t so that's again
something you'll get much more practice
with uh if you haven't seen it already
but that's a preview that comes in
response to einstein's work it wasn't
denied science owned originally although
just to jump ahead very briefly einstein
first thought that was horrible because
he didn't like mizkowski but then over
the next several years the better part
of a decade einstein himself became more
impressed by that way of thinking and
really adopted it for his own later work
on what became known as the general
theory of relativity that's that's for
later
okay very briefly here's the third part
of the material i want to share with you
and then hopefully some time for
discussion as well
so this this last part is much more
brief but
how do we make sense of this why was
einstein doing all this seemingly
unusual maybe even crazy stuff certainly
out of step with lorenz with his own
teachers like minkowski
what how can we account for einstein's
quite idiosyncratic approach to what was
otherwise a common set of questions
about the electronics moving bodies and
here's some some of my favorite work by
other colleagues by other historians and
physicists who really looked at this um
in great detail
so for a long long time i mean literally
for for the better part of 100 years
since people began taking relativity
seriously
which is a long time by now
it had become very common
to say well einstein must have been
motivated much like hendrick lorenz was
really like that much of that generation
was
einstein must have been kind of
responding to
the null result from michaelson and
morley and their interferometer but
einstein must have been trying to
explain why they couldn't measure our
motion to the ether
much as lorentz we know very explicitly
was trying to do
and there's a fascinating one of the
first really careful examinations that
claim uh was by gerald holton who's a
real
kind of hero of mine uh holton
uh did his first phd in uh in physics
low temperature physics and then
retooled many years later in the history
science and he wrote a series of really
remarkable essays about einstein
uh once a lot of einstein's papers and
letters and notes became available
holton was among the first to really dig
through these with great care uh and and
uh almost like a detective going through
the evidence
and what what holton concluded was it's
not clear that einstein even knew about
the michael simoerly interferometer
lorenz knew about it and followed it
carefully there's very little trace that
einstein paid it any attention at all if
he did know about it it was kind of in
passing it was certainly not sort of
front of mind
in the months and years leading up to
the 1905 paper
he might have known about it secondhand
from reading through all the footnotes
of loretz but it's not something he was
he was seems to have been paying much
attention to at all
and so there's nice textual evidence
even in einstein's paper that 1905 paper
that i keep showing some some brief
excerpts from
again this is on on the first or second
page
when he's trying to to um
to reason why we should think about
maybe giving up on the ether
he mentions without citing any of them
he mentioned several unsuccessful
attempts
to discover any motion of the earth
relative to the light medium the ether
he doesn't say which ones he means
but he actually then goes on to say the
same paragraph none of these have found
any deviation to first order in v over c
and what's so striking as halton reminds
us is michael simorley was actually
second order einstein seems to be
talking about a whole different class of
earlier experiments even before
michaelson got in the game
uh he seems to not to be he's not
obsessing over the michael simori
interferometer the way other people were
and so some people then read holton's
analysis to say a kind of
over-correction does that mean einstein
didn't care about any kinds of
experiments at all if he wasn't trying
to respond directly to the michael
symond experiment was he just often a
kind of philosophical dream world and
that's where i think we again can now
say quite firmly no
in fact it makes sense to go back to
einstein's own early years his his early
fascination with electrotechnical
gadgets and remind ourselves what his
day job was
in the early 1900s including 1905
put it back in the patent office in
central europe at this very specific
moment
so let's think about einstein's favorite
technology trains trains and railroads
themselves were actually fairly new in
the 19th century they were introduced to
widespread commercial usage for kind of
commercial transportation
uh really only in the 1830s and 40s
remember einstein was born in 1879 they
were relatively new even in his
childhood
during this whole time
until very late in the 19th century
there were no coordinated time zones
there was nothing like eastern standard
time or pacific time or
you know central european time
each town set its own local time and all
the residents could coordinate by
agreeing that we'll use that clock tower
either you know some municipal building
or often a tall church in the town
square
so that's our local time
we'll set our local watches to when that
clock you know chimes 12 noon
so each town kept its own local time and
before railway that was who would ever
need anything else because one was
rarely encountering more than one town
in a given day
after the advent of railroads you still
had this local time but that became more
and more of a problem it was true in
north america as in europe and other
parts of the world as well
so here in closer to to to boston
passengers riding on the train between
boston and new york during this time
would have to change their watches by an
average of 37 minutes you know today
we're all in the same time zone but
that's how different the sort of local
variations tended to be
just up and down the u.s portion of kind
of mid-atlantic sea coast and likewise
throughout europe
that was becoming more and more of a
problem
when you have to coordinate lots of
trains traveling through across large
distances
it wasn't only a problem for commercial
railway or for shipping
it became a very potent added challenge
in germany during einstein's youth
so again as many of you may know there
was there only became one single country
of germany a unified germany in 1871
following yet another war with france
that was basically the story of the
previous 500 years
german-speaking lands fighting with
french-speaking ones there was another
one the franco-prussian war throughout
1870
the german-speaking folks prevailed and
it was at that moment in the wake of
that war
there was then a first unification of a
country of germany now a much larger
expanse of what of what had otherwise
been independent german-speaking
territories
so now there's an added reason to worry
about trains that have to be coordinated
across distances there's now a new
country's worth that has to defend its
borders all the way from basically
poland or russia
on on the east and france on uh the west
and there's a famous quotation from a
leading uh german uh general counca
who in in the 1890s you know 20 years
into german unification is basically
saying we have a problem on our hands we
have to coordinate trains for military
purposes as well as commercial um uh you
know passenger rail and merchant
shipping
we have a problem with the fact that we
don't have unified time zones this is
all happening in einstein's childhood
remember eisen was born in 1879 very
early in this period of unified germany
and a new focus on coordinating clocks
at a distance
so one of the main ideas that many
clever people inventors came up with
throughout europe and other parts of the
world as well
was to try to coordinate clocks
and therefore help coordinate train
stations in these different cities that
you know europe much of continental
europe was now being connected by rail
if the train if the major hubs
of the major train stations could agree
on the time then you could set your
watch then and and uh and the trains
could be better coordinated
throughout even into the hinterlands
and the main idea that many inventors
and entrepreneurs kind of
zeroed in on was to install these
so-called motor clocks mother clocks
central clocks that you would say were
like the standard ones and then connect
those by electromagnetic signal either
telegraph or increasingly radio waves
literally traveling electromagnetic
waves in the ether
some of you might know that the eiffel
tower which is under construction at
just this period was originally built to
aid radio communication it was a radio
beacon before it was a reason for all of
us to go visit paris there were other
reasons for that
the eiffel tower was built really in
this period in large part to become a
radio beacon to broadcast standardized
time signals
and then the idea was you would know how
far you were from paris you know there'd
be some delay when you'd expect to
receive the radio beacon if it's 12 noon
in paris when that beam was sent you
have an offset based on how far away you
are in the speed of light that it would
take to get there
so then these very clever folks who make
all these kind of gadgets to both
receive the time either telegraph or a
radio wave
and then kind of um implement the offset
and then reset the clock in your next
train station clock and down the line so
imagine these coordinated sets of
coordinates where you have local clocks
at every at every uh important location
that are sending and receiving
electromagnetic signals to coordinate
their their local time that's exactly
the scenario that einstein mentions in
the abstract in the opening pages of his
1905 paper
he doesn't talk about these patent
applications but
or about trains in this more um kind of
practical way but it turns out as as my
friend uh peter galison uh shows you in
this beautiful book einstein's clocks
point grace maps this was the subject of
a kind of um enormous tech spree this is
like the tech challenge of the day
for all these very smart young
electrical engineers to build up and
patent every bit every switch in gear
for this way of coordinating clocks at a
distance often using uh electromagnetic
signals
not only that einstein was at the
electrotechnical part of the barren
patent office where a lot of these were
flowing through so he was an examiner on
many of the little widgets and gadgets
as part of this clock coordination
sequence even better my favorite part of
peter's otherwise quite fascinating book
was it peter and his research assistants
pieced together the walk that einstein
used to take from his apartment to the
office he had a lovely stroll through
baron during this time of his life and
then finding out when each of the clocks
along his route were wired up to this
now um coordinated system so literally
the clocks that i said would walk past
between his apartment
and his office were in this exact moment
being wired up in this new explicit
electro-technical clock coordination
system not just across distant train
stations but soon even across um the
kind of semi-urban regions where he
lived
it was literally his day job and and the
path that he worked and walked to get to
work so this notion of using
electromagnetic signals to coordinate
clocks in a kind of measurable
repeatable way
was of philosophical interest it was
certainly inspired in part by uh the
writing of air smock but einstein was
also immersed in a different set of
realities than someone like uh hendrick
lorenz or the other maxwellians and so
when it comes to the question of the
electronics electrodynamics of moving
bodies einstein's immersed in different
kind of conversations and day-to-day
questions compared to those of um the
kind of physics elite of his day
so we come back to this very um iconic
but kind of unusual
paper from 1905 on the electrodynamics
of moving bodies
i think we can make a bit more sense of
it informed by work by uh people like
peter gallison
the paper that i say is paper has almost
no references
much like many uh patent
applications you want to sort of
emphasize priority and downplay
precedence
default outside focuses on the
operational details how would you
actually perform these measurements and
compare the answers at some distance
it starts to look sort of like a patent
application not like a fancy exercise in
mathematical physics
so we can come back to this question of
why was einstein doing things
differently what was he up to
we see him really enmeshed in just a
different set of of ideas of
philosophical conversations of
mathematical techniques and also of
actual gadgets
compared to some of the other experts of
his day
you